hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from the video World
rapid championship this is round two in
both Magnus and Eric Hansen have won
their games in round one and now they
face each other the game features a very
interesting opening the B3 opening and
Magnus tries a very very uh sneaky
Gambit right out of the first four moves
so you guys will enjoy it again one of
those games where something happens out
of nothing uh really uh just uh very
very intense game uh great moves you
know have to be played with very little
time on the clock and that's what made
everything that happened possible so
let's dive straight into it Magnus with
the white pieces that opens with B3 like
we said uh the names of Larson attack we
have D5 by Eric very principled of
course if white doesn't control the
center you will grab the central with
your pawns and white will control it
with the pieces there should be two with
Bishop to G4 very annoying move as it
really asks white what um what kind of
uh uh setup do you want to play and also
you will play E6 without having to worry
to develop your light Square Bishop
later on so here Magnus plays F3 Bishop
to F5 and now Pawn to E4 already
offering um a pawn but this would be
very very dangerous to actually accept
this and it was attempted once by a a
strong player Joe Baba played it against
artemir the game ended in a draw but if
you capture the pawn then you don't
recapture you play Knight to C3 and then
after he captures an F3 uh not Knight
captures but Queen captures an F3
attacks the bishop attacks the B7 Pawn
now if you go back then you've lost all
of your development and if Queen the ca
then you continue in IV GT2 you can
Castle Queen side play D4 why it gets so
much development for the price of this
one pawn and Eric says I'm not game I'm
just gonna move back my Bishop he plays
Bishop to G6 and there is one game in
the database for Queen T2 was played but
here Magnus plays H4 and it is now
already as of move 5 that we have a
completely new game game so Eric doesn't
want to see a H5 on the board he plays
H5 himself that's a weird sentence but
that's how chess Works e captures on B5
by Magnus Queen captors and not Knight
to C3 kicks away the black queen queen
to the these you could also consider
Queen to a five every ghost Queen to D6
and now Queen to E2 Magnus wants the
castle Queen side and push D4 so Eric
says uh I don't think I'm I won't allow
this he plays Knight to C6 we have Queen
side castles and now he puts his Knight
on D4 stopping Magnus from playing D4
also attacks is Queen we have Queen to
C4 and Eric also castles Queen side if
you're wondering but what about the C2
Pawn as it seems uh Eric can just grab
it the problem is if you capture this
then Knights the B5 attacks the queen
and you can uh just resign here so
that's not really an option Bishop
captures is possible sort of attacking
The Rook because now the Knight covers
the B5 square but still after Knight the
A4 uh you will not have a great time uh
because now the the Knight is also
hanging and even if you you capture The
Rook on D1 this will still be very very
good for white for example Queen
captures Bishop captures the bishop on
D1 is hanging and you will have to grab
something let's say Bishop captures
eight characters and the white is again
very very happy having two pieces for a
rook so that's why after Queen to C4
Eric just castles Queen side and Eric
could not be happier with his position
on move 10 the Knight is in a
spectacular Square uh black king is
Castle the safety on the queen side rook
and queen control the D file the bishop
control this beautiful diagonal so this
is uh definitely the way to go uh Magnus
plays Knight to E4 you have to play this
because now this is is a threat attacks
the black queen and Eric just moves it
with knights the E2 putting pressure on
the Knight on D4 and Eric trades Knight
captures on E2 with check Bishop
captures and now Ponte E6 preparing to
develop the dark Square Bishop Magnus
goes King to B1 uh uh always a nice
prophylactic idea and now Knight to E7
and the Knight is now coming to C6 and
uh Eric is just saying there is no way
you can beat me in this position so A4
by Magnus uh Knight to C6 the players
are pretty similar on the clock I think
Magnus was maybe up by a minute seven
minutes to Six Minutes uh and he offers
a queen trade he wants to go for the end
game now and try to squeeze as much as
possible uh Eric plays Knight to D4 he
says sure let's trade Queens but we are
trading them on my terms and okay Queen
captures eight captures on B6 and now as
the bishop anito is hanging uh there you
can see the usefulness of Kingdom B1 if
the king wasn't on B1 rather if the King
was on C1 uh then after eight captures
on B6 you could throw in the nice in
between Knight captures on E2 with check
if the King was on C1 that's why it's
always useful to play a nice
prophylactic move Bishop to C4 and now
Bishop to E7 we have Rook D to E1 now
and Rook to D7 Eric wants to double up
on the D file Bishop to C3 by Magnus and
now Rook H to d8 and again Eric can
really enjoy his position nothing
really happening here in magnus's favor
we have King the B2 now maybe with some
ideas of Rook day one A5 and here C6 by
Eric the Knight controls the B5 Square
as well so B3 isn't is always an option
now and Magnus has to decide how to go
about this and it's not easy uh if
you've got something like captures
captures in D3 it's fine but you've
given up your dark Square bishop and you
have nothing to show for it so Magnus
goes uh where you should always go when
in doubt and that is Pawn to B4 now he
has some ideas of A5 he has ideas of B5
and he's basically asking Eric do you
want to play B5 uh yourself or maybe
Eric could also Eric has many many
options here like he could play he could
eliminate the Knight here uh he could
try something like uh well uh many
options just improving the position of
the king this is actually what he went
for King to C7 and now Magnus goes Rook
to A1 and again do you go B5 do you now
capture the Knight not capturing the
Knight and putting the bishop on F6 is
also a pretty good idea also B5 is very
nice now for Eric for example B5 a
capture C captures the bishop has to go
back now you play Rook to D5 and you are
very very happy here you can even put
the King on B6 and well black black
should just be either equal or better
but Eric went for E5 and this allows
Magnus to to actually try something from
this um well uh a position full of
possibilities and he goes for uh Pawn to
D3 first
uh adds another Defender to the Knight
ends to the bishop uh we have F6 by Eric
and now Magnus Waits no longer now you
don't want to play A5 then just B5 but
you do want to play B5 and this is a
very very tricky move so why did Magnus
play this what if C captures uh on B5
what happens here a character's on B5
and now uh What uh what do you play
probably something like uh Bishop to C5
you you just continue so while this is
possible Eric goes for Bishop to f8 uh
and now we have Rook H the F1 and here
uh Eric's position is still completely
fine but he is now down to two minutes
and the clock Magnus has over four
minutes on the clock and uh Eric who
goes for Knight to F5 here you have to
play Rook 8 and stop Pawn to A5 But Eric
played Knight to F5 and now Magnus uh
finally gets something out of the
position A5 and now there's a lot of
tension here you have to spend time to
calculate and Eric definitely did spend
his time and how you want to play this
is either King to B8 or even the very
tricky 93 attacks the rook and the
bishop so even after eight captures on
B6 you go King to B8 you most certainly
do not capture if you capture you just
get checkmated Bishop A5 check King has
to go to the a file and then you capture
here deliver um a nice check uh from The
Rook or even uh you could go Bishop to
C7 to prevent King to B8 even stronger
you don't have to capture the rook and
now only move is Bishop A3 and you
deliver Checkmate here so how you would
have to play this after 93 and they
capture some B6 is King to B8 and now
okay Rook uh moves attacks the Knight
here Knight captures Bishop D captures C
captures on B5 and black is uh very much
alive however C captures on B5 was
played and this just allows Magnus to
completely uh Revitalize his Bishop's
pair now this becomes definitely the
bishop pair from Hell Bishop captures on
B5 attacks The Rook Rook D5 attacks the
bishop but now a captures on B6 with
check and you again have to go back and
maybe you survived this game but Eric
boldly captured on B6 probably saying
okay if you play Bishop to A5 check then
I capture on B5 and now okay and not
much is happening if you capture a
capture back but even after C4 check it
would be better for Magnus but Magnus
tricks him after King captures on B6
Magnus goes Bishop C4 he says uh that uh
you do not have any control play here he
just attacks the rook and there is no
good way
uh to save The Rook as if you move the
Rook away from the from the control of
the fifth prank Bishop to A5 check and
you resign so here at night the E3 was
played sort of putting counter play
using an attack on the rook and F1 but
now just Bishop captures and D5 and the
problem is if you capture on F1 again
Bishop A5 check is deadly King B5 you
just play C4 sorry C4 with check and
after King Day 6 only now you capture
the rook and the eight opening up a
discovery from the rook and after Bishop
A3 this will once again be Checkmate so
that's the problem for Eric so after
Bishop captures on D5 Rook captures and
D5 was played and I'll just Rook after
B1 uh we have Rook the B5 check Magnus
goes back King to C1 and now Rook
captures on B1 Rook capture Sun B1 and
King to C6 so Eric avoids getting
checkmated but the problem is due to the
king being on B6 he had to give up the
exchange in order to survive the attack
G3 was played as G2 Pawn is hanging
Knights the D5 attacks the bishop and
just Bishop back to D2 and here uh after
Bishop to F7 uh the position is very
very bad for it is completely winning
for Magnus and also Magnus says almost
four minutes on the clock whereas Eric
has some 15 seconds on the clock and a
few more moves were played C4 Knights
the C7 and the bishop to A5 and he was
in this position unmoved 38 that Eric
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you you have zero
counter play okay you have the bishop
pair but it's not doing all that much uh
and there's really no point in yeah in
continuing this so Eric knows this and
this as he was incredibly low on time he
decided to resign so Magnus which two
out of two we'll see how how long he can
continue doing this and will he be able
to uh challenge uh Abdul satro's title
from last year or will we see a
repetition by Abdul satrov or will we
see something completely uh different
because uh it's a very very hard to
repeat the last year's success so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
very nicely done by Eric he didn't
um uh when Magnus went for this E4 move
he didn't go for D captors and E4 even
though Eric knows it's the strongest
move recommended by the engine uh but he
just knows that Magnus prepared to this
uh probably uh an unimaginable extent
and he just decided that Bishop to G6
was the way to go and he got a beautiful
beautiful position he got a very nice
game but uh Magnus kept draining the
clock and Eric just didn't continue in
the most precise way and that was enough
for Magnus uh so yeah once again really
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank Ricky black Lars Oliver yeah
groundhog uh Jeff Graves David Ross rice
Oxley and the David Kimura for her
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to all my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing uh to cover the
video World rapid Championship until it
finishes so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day